wolfgang thierse ist zweifelsohne einer
der angesehensten elder statesman in
deutschland bürgerrechtler in der ddr
ehemaliger präsident des deutschen
bundestages und 15 jahre lang
stellvertretender vorsitzender der spd
herzlich willkommen bei phoenix
persönlich einen guten tag wir wollen
uns heute unterhalten weil sie eben
mittelpunkt einer erregten debatte
stehen es geht um das was man noch sagen
darf oder vielleicht besser dicht sagen
sollte von zigeunerschnitzel bis zender
sternchen
es geht um meinungsfreiheit aber es geht
auch um die benachteiligung von
minderheiten die zu recht
gleichberechtigung einfahrten schwierig
ist aber spannendes thema
identitätspolitik und da hatten wir uns
gleich darüber aber zu kurz noch zuvor
kurz noch einen ausflug in die aktuelle
tagespolitik
man hat den eindruck dass nach der spd
auch die einzig verbliebene große
volksparteien nämlich die union in eine
veritable krise geraten ist wie
beurteilen sie denn den machtkampf in
der union
was mich daran erstaunt ist der umstand
dass cdu/csu nicht schon längst ein
verfahren entwickelt haben um diesen
streit zu vermeiden den man ja kommen
sah man konnte es mindestens einen wenn
man herrn soll dazu gehört hat und
seinen zahllosen auftritten und dass da
keine vorsorge getroffen wird wie man
das regelt denn das ist ein streit
zwischen personen gibt ist nicht
wirklich etwas sensationelles aber dass
man in dieser ausweglosigkeit sich hat
führen lassen das ist schon beunruhigend
jetzt müssen wir dazu sagen dass wir
dieses gespräch am donnerstagnachmittag
aufzeichnet noch wissen wir nicht wer
sich da am ende durchgesetzt hat sie
haben in der spd ja durchaus auch schon
solche duelle erlebt zb 98 zwischen
schröder und lafontaine hat sich am ende
schröder durchgesetzt weil er die
größere größere popularität bei der
bevölkerung hatte denn wenn das
entscheidende faktor ist dann würde es
ja sagt heißen 1 0 für st
nein das war ja damals nicht das geben
sondern gerhard schröder hat eine wahl
gewonnen in niedersachsen und zwar ganz
überzeugend und das war ein so starkes
argument für ihn dass oskar lafontaine
gesagt hat die klasse ihm den vortritt
laschet belegt man zu dass er vereinen
die menschen hinter sich sammeln kann
bei söder sagt man das ist der mann mit
der größeren führungsstärke
was ist ein wichtiger seinen kanzler
also für ein kanzler ist ohne zweifel
wichtiger die fähigkeit zusammen zu
führen denn wir leben in einer
gesellschaft die ziemlich disparat
geworden ist zerklüftet sagen manche hin
fast eine pluralistische und im streite
befindlichen gesellschaft die auch in
einem großen modernisierungsdruck steckt
wenn man die für herausforderungen mal
buchstabiert globalisierung digitale
transformation bewältigung des
demografischen wandels und vor allem die
ökologische herausforderung die
umweltkatastrophe zu verhindern
das verlangt dramatische veränderungen
in dieser gesellschaft und da ist nicht
nur das große wort notwendig sondern die
fähigkeit gegensätze zu überbrücken
gemeinsamkeiten zu finden zu bündeln das
ist glaube ich besonders wichtig wenn
ich das richtig verstanden habe war das
jetzt ein ziemliches plädoyer verlassen
ich habe ja da nichts zu sagen keiner
anderen partei an und ich sehe das mit
neugier interesse unter einer gewissen
besorgnis über die situation ihrer
eigenen partei wollen wir uns gleich
noch unterhalten im rahmen der debatte
die unser eigentliches thema ist ihr
habt schon gesagt identitätspolitik das
beschäftigt irgendwo sehr viele menschen
ist aber auch ein sehr sehr schwieriges
thema können sie vielleicht mal kurz
einführen warum geht es da eigentlich
also dass menschen gruppen ihre
interessen vertreten das ist teil der
demokratie das ist zu ihrem wesen
das war auch noch nie anders wenn damit
identitätspolitik keinen anlass für
aufregung aber dieser begriff
identitätspolitik den ich ja nicht
erfunden habe der meint doch dass
bestimmte prägung die wir alle haben als
einzelne wir als gruppe sozusagen
verabsolutiert werden
jeder von uns weiß dass sein die eigene
identität aus ganz verschiedenen
prägungen eigenschaften besteht aber
wenn eine davon
sozusagen nach vorne gesetzt dominiert
gegen die anderen gerichtet wird dann
entsteht ein streit an entstehen fronten
die ich für nicht ganz notwendig und
sinnvoll halte um es noch mal anders zu
sagen wir leben in einer pluralistischen
gesellschaft oder wie man eine
gesellschaft der diversität
dazu ist es vernünftig ja zu sagen aber
vielfalt pluralität erzeugt selber nicht
schon gemeinsamkeit und deswegen ist
meine grundüberzeugung ja zu vielfalt
aber wir müssen auch begreifen dass wir
die immer neue verständigung darüber
brauchen was uns miteinander verbindet
was uns gemeinsam ist was also das
jeweils eigene legitime interesse die
jeweils eigene legitime prägung
relativiert mit dem blick auf die
anderen und auf das gemeinsame das ist
mein votum
ich versuche das zu verstehen ja es geht
darum dass frauen gleichberechtigung
einfordern dass migranten schwule und
lesben ein ende der diskriminierung
fordern im prinzip sind ja fast 8
dafür also warum ist das dann schwierig
also in der insofern identitätspolitik
einsatz für gleichheit ist politische
rechtliche ökonomische soziale
gleichheit ist sie demokratisch ich sage
sogar ist die links ist
sozialdemokratisch und ist sie auch
unbedingt zu unterstützen
aber wir erleben doch dass es ganz
unterschiedlicher zugänge gibt es gibt
ja auch eine rechte identitätspolitik
gibt sogar eine gruppe unter den rechten
die sensen nennen sich die identitäten
die vertreten den positionen das
deutsche volk müsste als rein erhalten
werden
rechte in der tz politik führt in
vorurteile in ablehnung von anderen in
hass und letztendlichen gewalt und sie
ist entschieden abzulehnen
die linke identitätspolitik sagt noch
einmal so insofern sie auf gleichheit
vor dem gesetz
ökonomisch sozial zielt ist sie zu
unterstützen
aber insofern sie jeweils teil
eigenschaften teil prägung
verabsolutiert und sie gegen die anderen
richtet da wird es problematisch also
man kann das durchaus buchstabieren wenn
man gewisse man sagt wir wollen als
bürger ausländischer herkunft anderer
ethnischer zugehörigkeit anderer
hautfarbe die gleichen rechte haben wie
die anderen sich unbedingt zu
unterstützen
aber wenn damit verbunden wird etwas was
ja auch passiert dass der verdacht gegen
die anderen die nicht schwarz zum
beispiel sind der verdacht dass sie
tennis rassistischen dann sage ich dann
ist das die falsche freundin bilder und
die falsche konfrontation
wenn man sagt dieser gesellschaft ist
fundamental eingeprägt rassismus
rassismus gehöre alles kann man lesen
zur dna dieser gesellschaft dann sage
ich ja wie sollen wir uns von unserer
dna befreien können ich bin sehr dafür
dass man sagt es gibt benachteiligungen
wenn man schwarzer ist people of colour
show und das ist schon die sprachlichen
verordnungen sind ja ein problem
oder wenn man einen ausländischen namen
hat benachteiligung bei bildung bei der
suche und empfinden einer wohnung bei
der karriere und so weiter dann sind das
ganz konkrete rassistische vorfälle die
man bearbeiten und bekämpfen muss aber
der allgemeine verdacht weil man weiß es
ist man schon latent rassistisch der
macht denke ich hilflos denjenigen die
angegriffenen ist und ich sagte zu
meinem menschliche erfahrung
ich vermute es geht ihnen auch je
heftiger man angegriffen wird
umso mehr wehrt man sich dagegen und
umso weniger ist man bereit zu
selbstkritischer einsicht ich versuche
mal ein beispiel zu geben
früher da sind an drei
die kinder von haustür zu haustür
gezogen und einer von den dreien
unterwegs waren
der hatte das gesicht schwarz geschminkt
und heute sagen manche das ist ein no go
das geht überhaupt nicht das ist black
facing das ist eine verächtlichmachung
der schwarzen ist das jetzt
rücksichtsvoll oder ist das absurd also
da muss ich mal sehr auf seine worte
achten ich habe selber mal in einem text
das wort black facing verwendet und
dafür würde ich ohne hart kritisiert das
gehört ja zu meinen erfahrungen ich
beschreibe schreibe einen text in der
faz dessen ganzer sinn war eine mahnung
ein appell schärfen zu vermeiden die
balance zu halten zwischen dem
vertretende eigenen ansichten und dann
der rücksicht auf die anderen die
ansichten der anderen dann wird man
daraufhin sozusagen mit auch mit einem
skistock überzogen also dieser artikel
in der faz wird wieviel
identitätspolitik verträgt unsere
gesellschaft und sie haben da im prinzip
die these vertreten übertriebene
identitätspolitik für zur spaltung der
gesellschaft und dafür gab es sehr viel
kritik über die wir gleich noch sprecher
können wir gleich noch mal sprechen aber
bleiben wir bei diesem beispiel
ich habe das wort black racing verwendet
werden ist scharf kritisiert worden und
bemerkte dass ich dabei wahrscheinlich
viel zu naiv ich habe natürlich nicht an
die minstrel shows in den usa gedacht
dass er bei uns nicht gibt die hat sie
gegeben in deutschland in europa sonst
in das tor schoss das sind show
schauspielern sich schwarz gekleidet
haben und im grunde die schwarze
befolgen verächtlich gemacht haben zum
gegenstand der freundlich gesagt der
halterung und unfreundlich gesagten des
spottes und der erniedrigung
aber das ist ja nicht unsere kulturelle
tradition
ich habe an karneval gedacht ich habe
daran gedacht dass kinder sich ganz
selbstverständlich als indianer zum
beispiel verkleiden oder ich hab gedacht
an den speed in holland auch eine alte
tradition oder sie jetzt drei könige da
besagt dies im nachhinein des rassismus
zu verdächtigen heißt eine jahrhunderte
lange tradition
sozusagen zu verdächtigen aus einem
heutigen standpunkt
verständlicher empfindsamkeit und dann
sage ich als eine grundsätzliche
position
wir haben hinzuhören wenn bürger anderer
herkunft andere einstellung an der
orientierung ihre betroffenheit
artikulieren
aber vielleicht ist das ein vernünftiger
grundsatz die betroffenen sollen das
erste wort haben aber sie müssen nicht
unbedingt das letzte wort haben wir
müssen fertig bringen dass wir uns
einigen können weil betroffenheiten gibt
es auf allen seiten unterschiedlicher
art aber der andere ist immer ein
anderer
ich kann nie vollständig in seine in
seine situation hinein köpfen aber es
gehört zur kultur und jetzt kommen wir
dazu in anführungsstrichen black facing
es gehört zur kultur dass wir uns in
andere hineinzuversetzen versuchen was
ist das theater anderes was sind romane
was ist literatur anderes als sich in
andere hineinzuversetzen deren rolle zu
spielen um damit etwas über die zu
verstehen zu begreifen aber auch etwas
von mir zu erfahren
kultureller an eigen das ist ja heute
auch schon wieder ein übel verleumdete
sword ist eine der ältesten
kulturtechniken ohne an eigenen von
fremden gibt es keine kultur und in
diesem wechselspiel von fremden oder
bisher fremden und dem eigenen dass sich
dabei ja auch verändert gibt es keine
kultur und das verteidige ich aber jetzt
höre ich eine grünen politiker musste
sich entschuldigen dass ich daran
erinnert hat dass sie als kind gerne
indianerhäuptling gespielt hat dafür
würde sie kritisiert ein schauspieler
aus bad segeberg hat gesagt ich werde
nie wieder bei den karl-may-festspielen
mich rot anmalen und da sage ich
entschuldige diese art von
verdächtigungen das sind wie ich meine
aus betroffenheit herrührende
übertreibung die das verhältnis der
unterschiedlichen mit dieser
gesellschaft nicht erleichtern sondern
es eher verderben weil darin immer
steckt aus der betroffenheit heute ein
moralischer verdacht gegen alle anderen
jetzt sind wir zwei alte weiße männer
und und das ist verdächtig sind
übertreibungen die ich an bisher
beklagen manche aktivisten sagen jetzt
jetzt das geht gar nicht dass wir uns
jetzt über rassismus unterhalten weil
uns eben die erfahrung von
diskriminierung und ausgrenzung schält
und da sage ich noch einmal wir können
nie vollständig die betroffenheiten die
erfahrungen anderer nachvollziehen das
ist immer eine moralische wie auch
kulturelle anstrengung die der wir uns
unterziehen müssen
aber wir haben doch jetzt gerade erlebt
das ist ein wirklich drastisches
beispiel eine holländische lyrikerin
wollte und das war auch vereinbart mit
der autorin das berühmte gedicht von
gorman dass er vorgetragen hat bei der
inthronisation von beiden übersetzen
dafür wurde sie angegriffen dass sie als
weiße lyrikerin das nicht könne und das
nicht dürfe und da sage ich wie soll man
dann heute noch irgend ein antikes stück
das können wir doch gar nicht mehr
verstehen inszenieren wie können wir aus
einer anderen sprache etwas übersetzen
wir sind doch nie identisch und dass
sich diese verkürzung auf bestimmte
identitäts ausschnitte ist jedenfalls
etwas was er zerstörerische und unserer
kultur ist austausch wechselseitige
aneignung oder jetzt nochmal etwas
moralische ausgedrückt dass die mehrheit
lernen geduldig lernbereit ist zu
verstehen versucht was die situation der
anderen ist also zuhört ist notwendig
aber ich wünsche mir ebenso auch die un-
aggressive erklär bereitschaft
unterschiedlicher minderheiten die sich
erklären damit wir begreifen wie es
ihnen geht und das ganze auch so dass
wir es noch mal übersetzen ich sage noch
einmal die betroffenheit kann nicht
schon der richterspruch sein sondern wir
müssen es übersetzen in argumente in
verstellbares sonst glaube ich nicht
dass friedliches zusammenleben möglich
ist für das was sie da jetzt gesagt
haben was sie in diesem faz artikel
geschrieben haben da haben sie sehr viel
gegenwind bekommen zunächst mal auf
twitter da ist das vielleicht normal da
hieß es dass in reaktionäre
position aber dann haben sich auch die
spd vorsitzende saskia esken und ihr
stellvertreter kevin kühnert eingemischt
und die haben folgendes geschrieben da
haben wir eine tafel vorbereitet die
wollen wir uns jetzt mal anschauen
all das beschämt uns zutiefst und
aussagen einzelner vertreter innen der
spd zur sogenannten identitätspolitik
zeichnen ein rückwärtsgewandtes bild der
spd jetzt müssen wir dazu sagen da
werden sie nicht mit namen erwähnt aber
man kann vermuten dass sie und wohl auch
gesine schwan
gemeint sind auf jeden fall haben sie
sich betroffen gefühlt haben sie sich da
verletzt gefühlt nein ich habe etwas
ganz nüchtern dass kunden relativ
nüchtern
das wurde öffentlich dass es war ein in
einem brief einer einladung gab es diese
distanzierung von gesine schwan und mehr
und da das öffentlich geworden ist habe
ich dann fresken einen brief geschrieben
und wenn ihr euch unsere schämt oder auf
meiner kämpfe und meint uns von uns und
mir diskutieren zu müssen will ich dich
gerne fragen da ich selber 15 jahre
stellvertretender parteivorsitzender war
und immer meinte man solle mich und
meine äußerung ernst nehmen nehme ich
dich auch unter einer äußerung ersten
fahrer dich also ist man bleiben in der
spd schädlich oder nützlich das musst du
mir ebenso öffentlich mitteilen
wir haben uns inzwischen gesprochen
ausgesprochen diskutiert das ist
bereinigt und es geht auch gar nicht um
meine persönliche geschichte nicht mal
es geht noch nicht mal so sehr um eine
partei geschichte sondern es geht mir um
die zukunft der
verständigungsmöglichkeiten in einer
pluralistischen gesellschaft der
singularitäten der diversität und da
sage ich noch einmal dazu vielfalt aber
die vielfalt erzeugt nicht von selbst
gemeinsamkeit an der und für die müssen
wir immer neu arbeiten das ist mein
thema welche reaktionen haben sie denn
gekriegt aus der partei und der
öffentlichkeit die beiden
essen und köln haben sich ausdrücklich
für die wortwahl und dafür entschuldigt
und nun habe ich erlebt und das
überrascht mich selber meine ich habe
auf der einen seite einen schutzschirm
erlebt vor allem organisiert von der
community
da wird mir vorgeworfen dass ich zum
hass gegen homosexuelle in diesem text
aufrufe das nicht ein wörtchen darin
ich habe die schule freunde gefragt
lesen dass nach ich bin vielleicht
betriebsblind
sie haben das gelesen nein ist nicht
eine spur es hilft mir aber nichts
es wird weiter unterstellt ich würde zu
hass gegen homosexuelle auf rügen und
hätte keine empathie
das ist das eine da muss man zuckt man
kurz zusammen und weiß die zähne
zusammen aber auf der anderen seite habe
ich ein geradezu überwältigend das
ausmaß von zustimmung erfahren deutlich
über 1000 mails und briefe
das freut einen natürlich er aber dann
gibt es etwas darin was mich was mich
irritiert nämlich in fast allen mails
und briefen steht wir bedanken uns für
ihre oder deinen mut
sie sprechen etwas aus was uns bedrängt
was wir nicht mehr auszusprechen wagen
was uns unsicher macht und dann bin ich
wirklich irritiert denn als ich das
geschrieben habe habe ich wohl versucht
genau zu sein aber ich habe mich nicht
eine sekunde mutig gefühlt und jetzt
kommt das als echo und das stimmt mich
schon nachdenklich ich würde das gern
gern aufgreifen zunächst mal noch ein
zitat von ihnen wo sie da die reaktion
der öffentlichkeit beschreiben das
können wir auch mal anders schauen
ich bin mittlerweile zum symbol geworden
für viele normale menschen die ihre
lebensrealität nicht mehr gespiegelt
sehen in der spd die unsicher sind was
ich noch sagen dürfen und wie es sie es
sagen dürfen dass zwei dinge würde ich
da gern besprechen dass eine symbol für
menschen die ihre lebensrealität nicht
mehr gespiegelt sein und das zweite ist
das nicht mehr sagen dürfen fangen wir
mal mit dem mann
inwiefern sehen menschen ihre
lebensrealität nicht mehr gespiegelt bei
der spd
ich muss noch etwas anders ich habe das
kleine wörtchen normal verwenden obwohl
ich auch gleich noch mal
dafür würde ich würde nicht dermaßen
kritisiert und förmlich nieder gemacht
und in der nähe
das von autoritärem jahr von
faschistischen denkens gebracht das tut
dann wirklich weh weil derjenige der
normal sagt angeblich die anderen als
abnormal witz dabei habe ich es
verwendet in dem sinne in dem es in
deutschen am meisten gebraucht wird
nämlich normal im sinne von gewöhnlich
durchschnittlich üblich ich wollte damit
sagen
die zuschriften kommen vom ganzen
spektrum dieser gesellschaft sie ist
nichts extremistisches vom vom einfachen
arbeiter bis zum prominenten professor
vom schwarzen und schwulen bis ich weiß
nicht wohin das wollte ich in diesem
wort normal im sinne von üblich
durchschnittlich gewöhnlich breit nicht
extremistisch
aber da merken sie dass man für so etwas
sofort schärfstens kritisiert wird ist
ein teil des problems
aber jetzt realität nicht mehr in der
spd glaube das ist ja das geht ja aus
diesen vielen zuschriften davor da waren
ja auch viele sozialdemokraten und
sozialdemokrat ihnen dabei die sich bei
mir bedankt haben und gesagt haben es
ist doch so wichtig wie die haben ein
ganzes leben lang gearbeitet
ganz normal gearbeitet und sehen jetzt
dass die spd und oder in mein fenster
auch sagen erweiterten teil der
gesellschaft nur noch diese oder jene
gruppe achtet und sie ernst nimmt aber
uns die wir so ein ganz gewöhnliches
arbeit seines leben führen die kommen
gar nicht mehr vor
und das ist bezogen auf meine eigene
partei sage ich dann
wir haben ein teil der arbeiterschaft
schon verloren
wir hatten gerade gehört dass ein
gutteil der türkischen wähler uns nicht
mehr wählt und das sage ich wir müssen
darauf darauf achten wenn wir den
volkspartei bleiben wollen
die chance ist ja nicht erledigt wir
müssen das wollen dann müssen wir doch
nicht nur auf die verschiedenen
einzelnen minderheitsgruppe schauen die
ihre legitimen interessen vertreten die
wir ernst nehmen sondern wir müssen auch
hingucken ob das ein breites spektrum
und das ist jetzt die aufgabe das
gemeinsame und verbindende zwischen
ihnen suchen und zum gegenstand von
politik machen und das heißt vor allem
natürlich soziale und ökonomische fragen
ins zentrum stellen die immer noch
wichtiger sind gerechtigkeitsfragen
ins zentrum stellen die immer noch von
einem großteil der bevölkerung als
wichtig empfunden werden 22 dieses zitat
diese normalen menschen die wissen nicht
mehr was sie sagen dürfen und wie sie es
sagen dürfen
wo dürfen denn die menschen etwas nicht
sagen also neben ja dass ein empfinden
wie das ist nicht der punkt ob ich das
selber meine ich bin überzeugt dass ich
sagen kann und darf was ich was ich
sagen will
aber ich bin in einer privilegierten
situation ich kann es und ich darf es
und mir zugehört und ein text wird von
mir abgedruckt von vielen anderen nicht
die zum schweigen verurteilt sind aber
das ist nur ein teil der wahrheit was
ich beobachte und was mich beunruhigt
und das hat vielleicht damit zu tun dass
ich ihm von haus aus eben auch
germanistin ist ist eine tiefer werdende
spaltung der sprache auf der einen seite
ich nenne es mal etwas ironisch dass
latein das an universitäten und in
redaktionen gesprochen wird
die leute die rassismus sensibel und
gender sensibel sich ausdrücken was ich
gar nicht kritisieren will aber auf der
anderen seite sagt man auch wieder
ironisch das dumme volk das einfach so
weiter redet wie bisher und das ein
bisschen jedenfalls geht das aus diesen
vielen zuschriften hervor allergisch
darauf reagiert wird dass in gewissen
maßen von ver oben verordnet wird wie
sie zu reden haben
plötzlich sehen sie im fernsehen wird
jetzt geändert wird die sprache hat sich
verändert
und da sage ich ich verstehe die
irritation daran und ich alles was auf
dem verordnungswege in dieser hinsicht
passiert gefällt mir nicht so gut ich
vertraue auf die entwicklung der sprache
sprache ändert sich und auch sie wird
sich auch in dieser hinsicht ändern dass
wir auf merkel sind für solche
unterschiede des geschlechts
das ist alles in ordnung aber lasst doch
den menschen ein bisschen zeit weil
dabei kommen die nicht von kommt ihnen
nicht moralisch von oben daher
was passiert denn ihrer ansicht nach
wenn menschen das gefühl haben sie
dürfen nicht so reden wie sie gerne
reden höher also ich habe den eindruck
dass dort oder in den eindruck er die
befürchtung dass leute die sagen wir
können nicht mehr ausdrücken was uns
bedrängt und was uns unsicher macht das
führt dazu dass ein teil resigniert und
sagt es hat doch sowieso kein zweck dass
ich was sage es ist immer irgendwie
verdächtig ich werde das rassismus
verdächtigt des sexismus verdächtigt des
kolonialen denkens usw
die resignieren und andere werden
aggressiv und wandern nach rechts so fd
die das thema schon auf ihrer agenda
und ich will das ausdrücklich nicht ich
will das ausdrücklich nicht sondern ich
will dass wir demokratisch und
kulturelle vertrauen dass es
veränderungsprozesse gibt dass es
wechselseitige lernprozesse gibt die
aber nicht nicht so rabiat verkürzt
werden können und dürfen jetzt kommt bei
uns ja niemand wegen seiner
meinungsäußerung ins gefängnis sie haben
ja durchaus diese diktatur erfahrung
gemacht sie haben mehr als die hälfte
ihres lebens in einer diktatur gelebt in
der ddr
ich glaube an der stelle wäre es
natürlich schon wichtig zu betonen wie
viel anders da die situation in so einem
system ist ohne zweifel also ich finde
es furchtbar was gerade auf vfb seite
und bei manchen querdenker demonstration
immer ddr 2.0 und solche sein und stasi
methoden und somit das finde ich ganz
furchtbar wer das macht hat hat
offensichtlich die dann nicht wirklich
erfahren
also das ist schon ein unterschied es
geht nicht um eine diktatur sondern es
geht darum dass veränderungsprozesse und
verständigungsprozess eng geführt werden
und verkürzt werden und dadurch viel
laufen dass auch ich sage es noch einmal
falsche konfrontation entstehen
das will ich nicht
und ich wende mich deswegen einerseits
wenig rechte identitätspolitik
entschieden ab das führt so zu zu hass
und gewalt aber ich wünsche mir eben das
sozusagen die die die gleichheits
forderungen gleichheits anstrengungen
unterschiedlicher minderheiten so
artikuliert werden dass mehrheit
mitgehen oder um es nochmal politischer
zusagen eine grunderfahrung in der
demokratie ist doch die wer etwas für
minderheiten erreichen will der muss
dafür mehrheiten gewinnen und man
gewinnt mehrheiten nicht dadurch dass
man sie einer konfrontation aussetzt
dass man sie einen fundamentalen
verdächtigungen ausgesetzt dass man sie
frontal attackiert so ein
wechselseitiges werben um verstehen sich
aufeinander einlassen das ist nur so
wird man gemeinsamkeiten finden und
änderungen schritt für schritt voran ich
versuche dem noch ein bisschen nach zu
spüren warum ihnen diese freie debatte
ist so wichtig ist und da würde ich
jetzt doch noch mal gerne auf die
diktatur erfahrung zurück kommen
1976 da sollten sie in der ddr eine
erklärung gegen wolf biermann und für
seine ausbürgerung unterschreiben da
haben sie sich geweigert und prompt die
ihre stellung im ministerium für kultur
verloren
das ist die wirkliche diktatur erfahren
ja es ist das ist eine diktatur
erfahrung
man muss überlegen ich habe nein gesagt
wohl wissend was das für konsequenzen
haben könnten und ich habe die
konsequenzen getragen
ich hatte glück ich habe dann bin ich
arbeitslos geworden ich habe dann eine
andere gute stelle gefunden
das hat immer damit zu tun gehabt dass
sie dir da klein war und ich sagte mir
etwas ironisch halter dass alle
intelligenten und anstehen menschen sich
doch irgendwie kannten und sich
wechselseitig geholfen haben es gibt
solch ein alltags solidarität also
diktatur erfahrung heißt auch dass man
für sein wort bestraft werden kann für
haltung bestraft werden kann
ausgeschlossen werden kann dass es bei
uns zum glück nicht
aber trotzdem ist es wichtig trotzdem
ist es wichtig dass wir ein breites
spektrum von meinungen zulassen und der
rahmen für dieses mal muss becks um den
gibt das grundgesetz ab aber das
verrückte ist doch nicht von mir
initiiert hat es in den letzten wochen
und monaten eine ganze reihe von
aufrufen gegeben zur verteidigung der
meinungsfreiheit
neulich ein debatten räume offen zu
halten
also da ist offensichtlich ein breiter
gewordene besorgnis da dass das
meinungsspektrum verengt wird dass der
professor iks so dass nicht mehr sagen
darf der und der nicht mehr auftreten
darf in einer der kabarettist
ausgeschlossen wird
ich bin sofort ein appell unterschrieben
seite ich habe ihn nicht unterschrieben
sondern ich bin also bei den debatten
räumen nicht in kann sich noch gar nicht
aber ich bin schon derselben meinung
nicht weil ich weil ich meine wir sind
in einer bedrohlichen situation aber wir
sehen doch nach innen noch nach den usa
und sehen was sich dort entwickelt da
kommt ja das wort cancelled
und das sollten wir nicht bei uns
übernehmen
also es ist auch im interesse der
unterschiedlichen betroffenen
minderheiten dass die freiheit der
meinung als hohes gut verteidigt wird
das schließt ja immer die die ernsthafte
und wahrscheinlich auch
leidenschaftliche auseinandersetzung ein
ich hab doch nichts dagegen dass auf
meinen text in der faz leute kritisch
reagieren und sagen und dagegen
argumentieren aber es ist nicht so schön
wenn man mit einem sturm bedacht wird er
ja persönliche herabwürdigung zielt der
verdächtigungen ausspricht der
unterstellungen formuliert der also aus
dem argument in die persönliche
schuldzuweisung und verdächtigung
übergeht das finde ich ist nicht gut das
war ein energisches plädoyer für debatte
und meinungsfreiheit von wolfgang
thierse in phoenix persönlich herzlichen
dank an sie bleiben sie gesund
[Musik]